today we're talking about
uh two and a half d so what is two and a
half d well it's a pretty cool effect um
that's been around for quite a while in
motion graphics
and it's basically where you take like
flat artwork and that could be like
photos it could be graphics it could be
typography
it could be footage and
you make that flat
element look three-dimensional uh
usually by stacking layers and things
like that and back in 3d space
so i'm going to show you how
some tips and tricks for how to make
your
two and a half d really come alive
and kind of explain a little bit about
it
if you don't really understand how the
camera works the 3d camera
or how 3d layers work i would highly
advise you to go to
youtube check out
3d layer techniques and 3d camera
techniques those are two videos i
created way back in the day when i
started motion science
and they're very uh they're 20 minutes
each they're very in-depth uh they're
very well done
spend a lot of time creating those
tutorials so three
3d camera techniques
and 3d layer techniques are the two that
you need to check out if you don't
understand
3d inside of after effects also i would
plug ae academy
[Music]
volumes 1 and 2 if you don't
know all the ins and outs working with
3d stuff as well
so let's make a new composition
called tunnel
and it's my typical
hd tv 1080 24 frames per second
five seconds is fine click ok
here we are and we're just gonna start
by creating um a shape layer okay so i'm
gonna double click
this box up here and by double clicking
it creates a shape layer
um you know that from ae academy volume
one
and i'm going to open up the path here
and change this to
let's just make it 1080 by 1080.
and it's got a five
pixel uh stroke on it which is fine
um it'll work for this example
and we're gonna make it 3d right here
and
then we're going to
switch our views to two views and you
can do this a lot of different ways i
like to work two views horizontal
so there we are we're at top view here
which you can see here top view and this
is our active
view here when we add a camera this will
become the active camera view
but uh it's easy for me to work within
the top view or
the custom view one
um to really like set up
3d inside of after effects because that
is one of the downsides um at least at
the time that i recorded this is that
there's not a different type of
interface for working within 3d inside
of after effects it's kind of you have
to get used to it once you get used to
it's easy to work within some people a
lot of people complain about oh i can't
build 3d inside of after effects it's
too hard to work with well i've been
doing it since it came out
i mean how long ago was that
over well a long time ago okay
um so here we go so here's shape player
one i'm gonna hit p for position
it's at a z distance
or a z position of zero okay so it's 960
by 540 960 on the x 540 in the y and
zero at the z so i'm just going to
command d to duplicate this and i'm just
going to start offsetting these layers
back in 3d space
i'm ocd about working
with even numbers when it comes to
3d
um i just find it easier to manage and
easier to work with that way it's just
my weird thing so um in this case i'm
doing a thousand pixels just so i can
really kind of show you what i'm trying
to do here but you could work with 100
pixels
so here it is 100 pixels i'm just
slightly back in space you can see it
here if i switch this
back to top
you can see here
here's the second layer pushed back okay
so um
we'll go to a thousand so all of a
sudden it's gone off of here and that's
where a lot of people get kind of hung
up with two and a half d 3d
if you zoom out
there it is okay
so i'm gonna duplicate it again
p for position
and i'm just doing like i said i'm ocd
so i like things to be even so i'm just
gonna do a thousand
pixel increments
uh we'll duplicate again
and i'm going to keep going through
these here 3000 so you can see it's up
here at the top now
duplicate again
4000 duplicate again p for position
just repeating myself here you can see
there it is so here is zero right and
we're going back a thousand two thousand
three thousand four thousand five
thousand
um let's actually keep going back
6000
we'll go back to 10 position
7000 duplicate p for position
8 000
duplicate
position
9000
and you can see how it's changing over
here
one more time and we'll make this
10 000.
so
there's 10 000 pixels back so i mean you
can go quite a ways back here i i would
never
recommend that you go like you know
beyond like 50 000 pixels back i mean
you're getting way back in here when you
do that and at some point you're going
to hit a limit where it's not going to
let you continue to zoom out and see
your layers
at the same time i could take like this
layer here and i could duplicate it and
i'm just going to bring it underneath my
starting point just for um
[Music]
so it's clear of what i'm doing here
i could move it
negative a thousand so negative 1000 is
going to bring it
forward
and down here so let's go negative 1000.
you can see all of a sudden that one
popped in front here here is the very
edge of it
and duplicate it again bring that one
down and i'm just ordering them on the
timeline here just
to keep things kind of
clear negative 2000 is going to pop it
down again
and
that's probably good for now so you can
see here's the top view like i said
switch to custom view one there you can
see i'm all kind of zooming back here
and i'm holding down the space bar
and clicking and dragging and that's how
my hand
pops up here
[Music]
so here's our layers
back in 3d space okay pretty simple
looks like we're kind of like it's like
a square tunnel we're going through here
so next let me show you
what happens when you add a camera okay
so we went to layer new and then camera
now there's some settings in here i'm
gonna go ahead and turn off depth of
field this may or may not be turned on
for you
there's one node cameras and there's two
node cameras okay so again if you don't
understand all this stuff go to 3d
camera techniques
um
and i'll show you just really quickly
the difference here i prefer to work
with one node cameras
i don't like two node cameras have
points of interest which i don't like
sometimes i use them and i will use them
in a couple examples here so you can see
maybe i'll use them we'll see
preset custom
15 20 24 again 3d camera techniques
um i like to typically just go 28 to 35
that's just my own personal preference
it's just longer or longer lenses or
down here so we're you know we're
they're a much longer lens these are
much wider angle lenses okay it's just
like a real world camera so 35
millimeter
watch what happens here when i add this
camera
see how it kind of changed the
perspective
things kind of went back they look like
they look like all of a sudden the
layers kind of went back in space but
they didn't it's just the the camera
which we see here
if i go if i have the camera selected
and i go back up to camera settings
layer camera settings if i change this
to like
50
watch what happens here
see how that set also i'm using a longer
lens so we're more zoomed in
if i go up to like 135
see that so the camera
is still here it's still at a position
right here but the lens is really long
so i'll go back to 35 and watch right
here what happens
35 boom there we go if we go the
opposite way and we go up here like 20
you can see here the the area of viewing
is going to be much wider here it's also
you're going to see more here
so boom there we go
so
um
maybe let's just stick let's let's go
with 20 millimeters here actually no
we're not i lied
let's go back to 35
so 35 there we go click ok
there we go okay so
um it looks pretty much like it looked
before
a little bit of difference there but the
cool thing is now that when i hit p for
position i'm gonna go ahead and close
these down
so just we can focus on the camera here
if i start messing with my position here
i'm just going side to side here you can
see
how much more interesting it is to look
at layers
pushed back in z space right so we're
working with with 3d here
it's
3d 2 and a half d i like to call it i'm
going to go up and down here
and we'll use the z
so here i'm zooming in and out
undo that i can also take this and
select z and move it this way
i can select x here
and move side to side here
same with y
like this
and the other way is i can use my camera
tools which are up here in my tool
palette so we've got the unified camera
tool orbit camera track and track track
x y and track z
um if you hit c on your keyboard which
you can see here it cycles through these
so i'm not a huge fan of the unified
camera tool
uh personally i like to use
the rotation tool the track x and y and
the traxxas z that's just my own
personal preference
but again i'm tracking z so i'm clicking
and dragging
back is zooming out dragging forward to
zooming in
c for rotation i'm just clicking and
dragging and you can see
here we've got going on pretty
interesting stuff
let's talk now about
actually let's just set a few key frames
let's do that
so i'm going to set a keyframe there and
we're going to zoom in and we're going
to do like a quick
kind of push
back
so in my timeline
and i'm clicking and dragging here
you know maybe something like that
and i am at half res here so if it looks
a little bit pixelated
that's why
so there you go we're just doing a very
simple kind of pull back through the
boxes
so now something else that's really cool
about working with two and a half d 3d
inside of after effects is here under
camera options
we've got our zoom
which is here
and we've also got our depth of field
right below that so it's turned off so
if i turn it on
it doesn't look like much changed here
right so over here you can see
there's this whole
other plane that appeared here okay
that's our focus plane right this big
box right here is because watch when i
turn it off
it's gone when i turn it on there it is
so our focus plane is right here focus
distance it's pushed way out there so if
i pull this back
you can see here's our our viewing plane
right here our focus plan is way beyond
that
if i go to let's say the top view here
[Music]
see it's way out there so there's our
focus plan this is our field of view
this is our focus plane i'm going to
bring that way down actually i'm just
gonna type in like
a thousand so now our focus plane is way
down inside of here inside of our
viewing
area okay so let's say we want let's
back it up to
zero
and let's say we want to start
with our focus plane on this guy right
here okay
so i'm just going to extend the focus
plane
so it lines up with this square
which which one is that is
right here oh it's the ones
barely on the edge of the screen here
it's layer nine
by selecting these ones on the top view
i can pick different layers down here i
can also select them down here
until i find the one i want which is
right there perfect
okay
so again we've got depth of field on
see it here our focus distance is set
but there's not much depth of field
happening here and a trick that i use
i'm sure most motion designers use is we
just crank up the aperture so that's our
next setting here it's the aperture so
it's set to
17.7
and that's just a default setting
for the 35 millimeter preset okay so if
i change this to like a 50 millimeter
preset the aperture changes right here
to 25.3 if i change it to 80 it changes
to 40.5 the zoom also changes okay so
um that's just a preset number for the
35 millimeter camera all i'm going to do
is crank this up and as i crank it up
you can see here
things are out of focus back here right
so now if i preview this
our preview is a little bit slower now
because we've got depth of field going
on
but
you can see there's actually some some
blurriness or some depth of field going
on now it doesn't look amazing because
i'm working at
half res
i go to full res it looks a little bit
better but the other thing to keep in
mind is that the iris shape is set to
fast rectangle this is a
standard
preset this is like the standard default
for the 3d camera inside of after
effects and it's not
the greatest look a lot of times i can
get by with using fast rectangle and i
do get by using it
but if you want
a really nice depth of field
you don't want to stick with fast
rectangle part of the problem here is
that our our stroke width is very thin
so it's trying to blur this very thin
stroke with here and it's just
not looking so hot so
you know you can pick any of these
hexagon works for me a lot of times so
you can see all of a sudden there's a
little bit nicer depth of field i'm
going to undo that and watch these
corners especially
so that's fast blur fast rectangle
it just doesn't look so nice
so hexagons there um it looks great
so again i could uh preview this and
maybe actually what i would do is i turn
a little bit of motion blur on here just
to make it look a little bit more
realistic
motion blur a lot of times you know
helps add that little bit of realism
to our cg it's not always necessary
though i don't always use it but let's
take a look at this
okay so there we go there is our very
simple uh tunnel setup with uh just
shape layers with a very thin
five pixel uh stroke
can't talk today um
and up the field
and just doing a very simple pullback
but you can see here the power of
3d layers
and 3d cameras inside of after effects
[Music]
you